Russia's space agency successfully
launches its lunar lander into orbit in
a race to touch down on the South Pole
of the Moon
but India had a head start when it
launched its own mission last month
there's a lot of competition I guess to
see who can get back to the Moon
um
first Japan obviously had a failed
attempt earlier this year Israel had a
failed attempt a couple of years ago
with their bearish heat Lander so really
it's kind of um you know up in the air
as to who's going to get there first and
who's going to be successful Russia or
India Russia's mission was originally a
joint project for the European space
agency but the agency bricked as Moscow
after it began its military mission in
Ukraine last February
since then Russia has been collaborating
with China which is expanding its space
Ambitions
now the competition between China and
the United States and lunar exploration
is more visible but you need to
understand that studying the Moon is not
the goal the goal is political
competition between two superpowers and
a number of other countries who also
want to claim the title of space
superpower it's Russia India Japan
no spacecraft has successfully landed on
the South Pole of the Moon known for its
Rocky terrain but it's an area of
interest because ice water is present
there scientists say it could support a
human settlement
the main task is simply to land on the
moon to learn to recover lost Soviet
expertise and to learn how the new
generation of developers can perform
this task
Russia was the first country to send a
man into space in 1961 and Prides in its
soviet-era space Legacy
landing on the South Pole of the Moon
would restore Russia's position at the
Forefront of space exploration Barbara
and gopa Al Jazeera